yeah hello welcome to our Monday night
it's night year right so yeah I hope
everything's working all right
we still have to fight some small
teething problems and I should actually
switch to the correct senior so welcome
to the broadcast let's get going with
some chess here any questions already in
the chat I'll have a have a look how
many times have I been asked what is the
good aggressive opening to learn with
little theory yes indeed quite often and
there is some there is not much that is
kind of aggressive and has little theory
let's see I want to play some games iam
going to shoot for a 5 minute game yep
yeah I flicked the scene a little bit
late game started I'll kill you on it
the first game you don't want to make it
easy for me here one of my top opponents
yeah this is a cool statistic 32 games
and we've got 15 wins 15 losses in two
draws which is kind of cool
ok I had a question what after c4 Knight
f6 Knight c3 e 6e for the mckenas attack
of them of the English opening what is
the best for black to equalize yeah I
guess d5 is the approved move down it it
should I mean this is not an easy
quality but black has very decent
chances to get equal plane so what to do
here after C form ok I'll do something
funny I just take them and play a solid
setup there's a question by a gaijin
schoo he wants to learn the Queens
gambit declined
to cover any good book on that well
there is some there's a book from 2011 I
think by John Cox declining the Queen's
Gambit which is the most recent book on
on this it's quite funny that the Queens
gambit declined while being a super
classical and and actually rather
popular opening especially on a club
level has so little coverage in books I
was actually thinking about this if I
should maybe make a book project about
the Queens gambit declined with black
there is this book by Cox which is not
bad at all but I think that it's still
an interesting subject to cover ok I'm
going to jump to c4 here that's maybe
not ok he's going to trade but I don't
mind that I've got less space so trading
is fine there's a question how do I
begin with getting my skill approved hmm
don't quite get the question do you mean
improved how to improve your skills if
you mean that well this is the the most
general kind of chess
yeah training improvement question that
there is and it's not not an easy to
answer question if you want an idea what
is the most important skill that you
should should you learn and improve this
is definitely calculation and abilities
and tactics because most games I decided
on that and this applies to a very right
range of players strength up to the
titled title players okay so he saw that
I'm attacking the pawn on d4 and decided
to give his bishop
there's a question I should tell
something about my team competition from
yesterday huh I don't mind that it's fun
it's a funny question because yesterday
my team played them in the German second
league against the team of current ports
the the best team of that division and
we actually managed to lose all eight
games so we didn't even get a single
draw which also means that of course I
lost my game it's it was a pretty pretty
clean victory here for my opponent Luke
when really was my opponent very nice to
get such a strong player but I could
really put up a fight it was some it was
just not good I didn't have a good
position out of the opening it was
slightly worse and then he very
convincingly I thought outplayed me at
least that was my impression during the
game I did not yet managed to analyse it
in any depth but it would I would be
surprised if I had some some real
chances somewhere it really looked like
a clean win yeah here there's not much
going on I can offer draw yeah I'm not
sure if he wants to I mean maybe he
wants to try he's a fighter like a black
King f2 and say I'm basically claim that
he's got some a little bit more space
you know he would probably play on I
would probably also play on here to be
honest the best way to defeat the
elephant gambit hmm no idea to be honest
I never looked at this opening shouldn't
be particularly great I would pick
rather surprised if it is any good
yeah I was surprised to see that there's
a question about we shot a report
beating Levon Aronian in the Bundesliga
yes I also was surprised it was a very
strategically focused game and report
managed to to win quite convincingly
against Aronian yeah I mean a report is
definitely a very talented player but he
sometimes over over does it with with
the crazy openings I think if he starts
to be a little bit more conservative
that can actually help him okay so I'm
not sure this is a good move but I have
to play one sooner or later
I think the King and pawn ending is okay
I play King g6 and h5 I hope I don't
miss calculate which is very easy very
easily done in the key and porn ending I
thought I take King g6 King III h5 and I
should be okay I might be wrong now I
definitely won't play the elephant
gambit on the stream it's tough enough
in the 5-minute pool anyway and playing
playing such such openings is not a good
idea for me I'm also not particularly
good in those kind of crazy positions
twenty-eight of Queen to g7 okay it's
not going for anything like that go do
this check the default porn I hope I'm
not running into some kind of wet
himself made him always able to do that
I've got talent quite talent for quite a
talent for screwing things up royally
but at least I'm not down on the clock
this is scientist is helpful now it
looks it looks dry yes I have played
Crazy Horse here and of course it's
funny
check I didn't see a reason why not to
activate here a little bit
it's chief G for crazy here
it's Queenie five huh
that's not a great idea Queen at four
though
oh maybe mmm don't know if Queen of four
is a move time warning hmm I can also
just go back office let's just go back
maybe I should have played for win
harder yeah I mean you can trade no no
doesn't trade check you can call the
draw just by checking her check it you
will do so check yeah I cannot play for
Winnie unfortunately check check then go
to have six but that doesn't really do
much King to e6 and it's still wrong
it's a draw which we don't term we don't
draw often but sometimes it happens okay
let's play another game the hillbilly
attack this I think this is against the
current right I don't think it's
particularly great but it's not like an
am an expert my information or idea why
this is not good is just it was asked I
think and Gustafson was once asked about
this in one of his videos and he just
said it's nonsense and I tend to believe
go Steve
and the Kings Indian with black oil
played that quite a lot actually on my
channel and I hope we can play it of
course in one of the next games the
Evans cavity I can play some reform with
white there's a question about new
content on my own channel besides blitz
videos yes there will be some other
content for sure and I can also tell you
when I'm going to move to my my new my
new apartment this week and when I'm
settled in which means like in a couple
of days hopefully I hope there is no big
issue with the internet and so on this
this can't be an issue that they screw
up my internet connection or things like
that if this is not the case and I'm
just I can just work in the new place
then I will come up with some new
content pretty quickly and yeah I just
hope that everything works fine there
for it for example I had today found out
that that in one of the rooms the
heating is not working which is kind of
important you don't want to don't want
it want to freeze so it's something that
I also have to have to look after but I
definitely want to do more content for
the channel it really was on on hold for
a long while because I'm constantly
doing stuff out of the outside of chairs
so okay I think I'll try to trade this
Seifer yeah I know that idea that was
presented my Mihama Rena also in his
books that this bishop here now is not
good but well I have c6 and 95 possibly
don't think it can be that bad
the Queen's Indian defense why is it
rarely encountered a top-level despite
its solid solid reputation and that's an
interesting question I've asked myself
this question I think the main reason is
that the Queen's Indian is an opening
where why it has a couple of options to
play against it it's got a three g3 and
some variations in those and black has
to be ready for quite a wide variety of
options and in some positions I think
the situation is not that how do you
call it it's not that engine friendly I
think there are many many ideas and not
so much in terms of concrete lines so I
think that nowadays people they go for
the top players they go to mostly two
lines that they can analyze in depth
with the engine and I think the Queen's
engine is not perfect for that I think
they'd rather go for some Queens gambit
for example where they can analyze in
much more depth I'm a bit surprised that
he just gives me the pawn there I think
my position was good anyway but still
surprised Bishop g7 SG for me so that's
not working and now so Queen to c7
threatens mate mate is a good thing to
threaten so let's let's try that on
so that's actually a good move didn't
really have that on the radar that much
but okay this question do I think that
you can play the decent class level
without memorizing many lines yes
definitely yeah if you are if you are
clever with your opening choices you
don't need to study that many concrete
lines very positive about that with
white you have many openings that are
more like setups than lines openings
like the red tee the Kings Indian attack
some queen pawn openings this is all
playable without memorizing a huge body
of theory and with black it's a little
bit a little bit more difficult I think
if you want to have a decent position
yeah here I'm a pawn up that's good but
am i winning is the question that's the
question I'm surprised that you did that
I am a pawn up right then I miss
counting yes
so Queen takes d5 is a bit of a strange
well takes takes King is seven now okay
but f6 now right
isn't that now that's not necessarily a
win okay let's bring the King
yeah mate is a good thing to threaten
this is the kind of wisdom you're all
expected from a show like that yeah I'm
happy I'm happy to provide it what I'm
wondering is if were actually winning
this king of porn ending that's not so
clear actually takes takes King III well
that's an interesting move threatens
some things I go back here the current
requires some memory and if you wanted a
position type like the karo with less
memories as a memorization it's not such
a bad idea to play the Scandinavian for
example it also has some memorization
where it is difficult without completely
without but you can play in a way that
it just requires doesn't require that
much so yeah it's not easy to win iam
really isn't yeah I would I would
definitely like to play a match with
with John but this is all after I have
changed places
recently I he stumbled into the Queen
trade him yeah next one I will also I
would also like to play a match with the
uncouth soft song I think John would be
would be up for it
of course he's the heavy favorite but
still it's something that I will try
after I've gotten that move out of the
way in started currently the only place
in my in my in my home that looks kind
of normal is my is my office where I'm
sitting at the moment the rest is all in
boxes and pure chaos
okay I've got some funky funky Stonewall
type of position here let's take them
not sure about this stone one with 96
yeah that the night is somewhat wrong
once is six yeah David I agreed to in
some way I think I mean I think I saw
the match between John Bartholomew
friends and and and young and I think
well I have not John's Co which but my
my I would say that he played a little
bit too with too much from yeah upside
down is um it's probably not a bad way
to put it but you said it I'm it's a
maybe and this is not my native language
in English I don't want to put it in in
a negative way just it just felt that he
was was a little bit too maybe a little
bit starstruck or something like that I
don't know I I definitely wouldn't have
played the openings that you that he
tried I think it didn't worked out well
for him at all especially the wide
openings looked to be it yeah I should I
should play one year for with wide
you're right I'm the thing is you always
say I have let's play the Evans gambit
and so really I really don't mind doing
it my issue is I simply forgotten forget
about it when I'm when I'm white and
just automatically play my boobs my
normal moves
okay I'm going to take him
yeah I said well I saw that match I
didn't I didn't see she's John's version
I watched yangu Susan's version didn't
have time for both and if John thinks
that he should have played different
openings I think he's right in that
especially with white that night and
three g3 stuff I mean I know what I'm
talking about because I play those
openings with white and if the other guy
has a good repertoire against that you
get absolutely zilch and this was the
case I mean Gustafson is a very good
theoretician and he got the better
position in most games pretty quickly
when he had black and this is that
that's not good and I Pro totally miss
played this game by the way there are
goals in over goes in this coach it's a
good opening sure Queen h5 was really
really a weird move my light squares are
absolutely bad maybe I can get in G 4
that would be fantastic but rook
air-five has been unexpected and now I
get in g4 that'sthat's great actually 27
I thought was much stronger this is not
so bad now
no Knight f3 g3 is not a bad opening
it's just that there are some lines
against it that I that are very decent
and when young played those lines I
think you should switch you should
switch and do something else you cannot
play that like 4 or 5 times and our
worse with white all the time ok cover
that this is something Kalashnikov is
playable yes sure it's not a bad opening
what do we have many questions here what
would I play against young Gustafson
with white and then tin that in the
bleach and blitz encounter probably
probably d4 main lines check which is
not easy I mean Gustafson is a very good
player and also very good theoretician
so it's difficult anyway but
yeah I think d4 main lines are better
and better should better shot and John
knows that also quite well so anyway
it's also a little bit like hindsight is
always 20/20 so I have never read any
Nietzsche I'm not good at philosophy at
all I never really wow what what move
was that that's kind of surprising that
he opens up everything here I'm not good
on philosophy at all I've never read any
anything basically I'm pretty decent
with some other areas like history but
philosophy is something that I'm not not
not good at or well informed and
informed off
yeah I said got some issues there what
to do now his his Bishop here cannot
move
is there something even better than just
a form mmm
it's good it's good just play it for he
wants to play c5 and possibly d4 all
right maybe
hmm yeah I think I have some seaport as
well huh I can and I cannot take them
let's go with a seaport and no there
isn't a winner I cannot believe it
timeline ah what did I do that
this is a bad technique of plane Ronna
that was bad wasn't good at all that
game should have be much much clearer
and I shouldn't have gotten all that
play and why didn't I go with the a pawn
that was my original intention actually
okay
I think it still wins but it wasn't it
wasn't good at all so what's that
quicker when I don't see a quicker win
black reasons yeah okay I was a bit of a
via technical play him but I hope I
didn't screw it up a bit later okay okay
playing G bianchi okay I'll go here for
now against such high rated player it's
a bit bit of a dicey move for me at
least so I play them the Smith Maura I
got requests for that last week I played
a fantastic Queen sacrifice with dismiss
Maura my opponent took it and I resigned
yeah let's see this is what I know
yeah plenty for I managed to get that in
yes this line
I have no idea I think I have to do this
right maybe just play strategically
another question by David Franklin who's
got the least chances in the candidates
video Auto part of what some suggestions
interesting interesting question um no
hard to tell really hard to tell I also
don't give to pile of much chances to be
honest as Villa also is of course is an
underdog but I think it's it's a pretty
open it's a pretty open race I mean
you've got some some people are more of
favorites or something than than others
but it's not it's not a super clear
thing okay is this it crazy to try some
g4 business here from the idea so I
haven't checked out the chasuble website
I know that's in the website that has to
do with chess openings but I have not
checked it out so I cannot give you any
positive or negative kind of information
there
g4 is a very dicey move yes and I can
take and play rook c1 this is the thing
my dad oh this one
okay that's also interesting it's hard
to hard to tell who's the who's the
possibly toughest challenger - Carlton I
think Carlton will beat all of those
guys in a match the fears completely
focused and in good shape I as I said I
waited I could be three actually he's
got Roxy three now and why took that
ages from him I'm an idiot
B 3 what a bad move what a bad move ah
wow that sucks it really sucks
I assumed it didn't look at all giving
him the c3 square was absolutely
terrible I just have to go Bishop e3 or
so these are the the really annoying
things give give the opponent this kind
of this kind of thing here heads really
bad
I don't think there was much going on I
had some compensation for the porn you
mean not not great or anything but good
enough
hmm interesting what did he trade he's
getting t3n right this is the thing
don't really get much what he does here
which is probably my issue and now he's
got Queen Queen pin know what I know I
can do Queen f3 actually okay okay yeah
the match that I would like to see most
is actually of course Nakamura because
this is the most interesting flash of
personalities made him so I would I
would look forward to that very much
even though if we look at the scores
thousand is certainly the heavy favorite
in that match but it's not something
that I don't I don't think that Nakamura
is necessarily losing that match without
any without any any chance of citizens
doesn't doesn't need to happen he just
has to break that spell once and win a
game then things will be will be
different I know that's nice I think he
traded too much I mean he's still better
yeah but difficult to win of course okay
I'll take the draw whatever ib3 wasn't
absolutely terrible move here I don't
want to make me much of analysis but b3
is just terrible Wow
I mean if I play something like this yam
and and just play normal stuff like
this this is a pretty good Bishop I mean
he's got a pawn this pawn on d4 word my
bishop is very active and if I can get
in stuff like that I have some counter
play here I think this is about equal
and the engine agrees
okay one more game
game started okay play the fighting
dragon who is that actually
International Master Chris Christian
cupca from Germany okay
I don't know him really I mean no in
person what books I would that's a
question about endgame books for 1,700
player pushing forward with chess
there's a standard recommendation you
can go for the de la Vida book the 100
end games you must know which is pretty
good for 4 basic the basic basic endings
the simple ones very little material
this kind of this kind of thing and for
more complex endings
I think the Gretzky's endgame manual
should be the one yeah and yeah David
Franklin's also is also suggesting good
book Jonathan Hawkins amateur - M - I am
that's also an interesting book with
heavy emphasis on the end game night bTW
- isn't there some Knight g4 here isn't
that an idea is that crazy
a special special t5 coming maybe
let's try really don't know yes
yeah I thought Queen d7 it might be
wrong entirely might be normally they
play h3 after Bishop h5 but I never
studied Bishop h5 duets Keys endgame
manual is it's a super is this really
really big book and it will have many
things that you probably if you are 1700
player that you don't need because it's
a complex but it's very comprehensive it
has everything in it so it's kind of the
thing that you it's it's the book yeah
so it does make some sense to get it
yeah I think white can maybe just take
c6 take e5 that wouldn't be a terrible
choice I'm sorry I have to drink
something it's playing in a mouth in a
more sophisticated way okay let's get
out of this
and I could move his unpinning and
activating the Queens I'll have to take
now do I take on D for now hmm maybe now
98 I'm blundering on moving the knife
blundering e5 but that's under fire
anyway I can actually play Knight da de
5 C 6 and trap his bishop
that's a funny more let's try that it
was so weird yeah I know the book
fundamental chess openings by poor
vendors Turin that's not a bad book it's
it's a it's an overview of all openings
basically it has everything yeah
obviously in a very short in a short
form but if you just want a complete
overview of everything it's not a bad
book at all this is however something
that you nowadays can probably also oh
hi he was clever he was clever him mad
my look is not protected hahahaha okay
okay I can take now though and the d2
Knight is hanging I never planned any of
that but maybe it works out funny and
stuff like this this book by vendor
starin with an overview of all openings
this is something that nowadays can be
done with Wikipedia in some way it's
funny I have a decent position now and
this is so lucky I never saw any of that
it was just pure coincidence this I'm
taking white
yeah he was probably irritated by the
whole thing here it was really strange I
was really thinking I'm trappin his
bishop here and he found that which I
didn't see at all but I can play this
miraculously and Knight takes e5 I can
take T - I was just luck I never saw any
of that 98 is actually a good move but I
couldn't I just I just I just got lucky
here and here my position is fine yeah
I've got the two bishops I've got 96
coming up and he just was very generous
with that piece what we had game yeah
okey-dokey next one and I'll go fo again
with white I think we had some good
players on in the five minute poor got
conrod hold for example on what is
playing at the moment probably not going
to going to get paired
come on give me a game
someone in the chat says suggests she
naps yeah some some liquor no I don't I
don't I cannot drink any schnapps
impossible everything I've got is
already in boxes no no no joke
I don't have much anyway don't drink
much alcohol but I've got the little
things that I have stolen already yeah I
want to do more I know I want to do a
bit more variety on the channel some
other time controls but also some
instructional videos so it will just be
a better variety but I have to see what
what happens what I ultimately go form I
mean how it is balance is what I'm
trying to say between instructional
content and and and other games of the
time controls okay I've got some some
French to fancy em and I think this is
probably quite decent for black I've
played some comparable lines myself when
I was still playing in the French and
usually if you get this good cue inside
Knights you're usually okay so I think
he is probably alright iam I need to get
something going here the time control
with the strongest players that I see is
probably in five minute three minute is
also pretty pretty strong though
not sure that is a very clear result of
you to a statistics statistic on that I
think five minutes maybe a little bit
stronger
yeah this looks very okay for black but
sometimes the Knights I mean the thing
is when I play that with black
I'm usually getting checkmated and if
I'm white I'm getting our plate on the
queenside
I simply have problems with this
position positions position type anyway
my next move is f5 unless he is doing
something pretty drastic this is
something drastic I can still go at five
but I think our capture yeah I know a
fire for this is kind of f5h form hmm h4
I can go back to e2 and allow him to
take on f5 yeah that's not so convincing
that think about this for a moment here
yeah maybe maybe this kind of thing yeah
three minute is also strong on the IC
definitely
yeah okay six yes he does his things and
I do mine but how do I get something
going Rock g7 maybe just go on the
seventh it's a bit on its own but
attacking f7 is annoying I guess okay if
I go Queen g1 I'm threatening Bishop g6
yeah yeah
Bishop g6 is the threat and probably
Luke g8 as well okay can I sacrifice
Queen g6 back it's close it's definitely
close
bishop h7 has a move now threatening
rook g8 again yeah that looks dangerous
oh they're question that I cannot answer
of course there are but that's one
particular question what do I think
about that Yelp girl writing the letter
to the CEO I don't know the story sorry
cannot command on it I don't know that
story at all
okay so yeah but here Bishop g6 is good
right
I have looked at civilization 5 but
didn't like it much even with the
additional packs or what they have now
is I don't like it somehow yeah I don't
look f8 is the only no it's not the only
move I thought it is check check
check okay so I'm winning the rook here
and I hope that I'm not getting killed
with some kind of wacky counter-attack
or my queen gets trapped or something
crazy so let's see my queen doesn't have
many squares Bishop c6 is that really
happening
Wow
Wow it's my queen getting trapped yeah
maybe maybe rook f7 was winning but this
is this is not winning I cannot believe
Allah what a mahi I'm a real cop right a
full rook and it's called bishops is six
coming out rocking out sexual queen
what what what else come on I'll second
the Queen it should be a pretty good
position actually after Queen takes d8
check check that shouldn't be bad the
pawns are pretty strong
his only move is B form I think that
yeah that that's the only move to put up
some kind of resistance the thing is
what to do I think I actually do this it
looks strange but it keeps the position
together Bishop can come to be form it
keeps things kind of harmonious I hope
that was the point so this is covered
and now I need the rook here for rubgy
aid yeah so I've got my Queen trap but
it didn't turn out to be that bad
yeah getting fired for writing a letter
to the CEO complaining about fake
payment mm-hmm well it depends it was it
there wasn't justified I don't know you
should be able to kind of express your
opinion but within reason I guess okay
I'm going to go here and this one yeah
it's kind of weird here in this position
I hope I'm not overlooking some kind of
tactic can easily happen three in g7
there's no made threat at the moment but
it still looks weird
Jeff is checking me there and by my
light
whoops it's got this check check check
check check check
oops okay what happening here check
check check
why did Jeff it's on time I didn't Wow
what the heck
ah yeah I lost control of that position
I was of course a complete win year
after the Queen sacrifice but I just
complete control that he somehow sneaked
in there probably I have to play some
some other moves like a seven or so yeah
yeah I should win after I'm 40 seconds
up and everything
some be seven
whoo okay so a new game yeah there were
a couple of wins I guess available the
way I played here that was also should
also win bishop g6 yeah this is this is
getting getting the better just do this
he's cut off I just have to cut him off
then the e pawn will win the game this
is plus seven or so but yeah happens
happens
here it starts to get get tricky and GM
lose the entire okay playing just kid
okay this is this is one of those guys
we have a terrible score one out of five
and yeah let's see what happens
the young Bianchi does good game by
black well no not really
it wasn't good game by black but it's
what happens sometimes you have a
totally winning position and you screw
it up it wasn't good bug like okay did I
just make a mistake here that's possible
right yeah stumbling into this this this
is trickier again I've lost it F lost
with this
I've lost with this earlier oh my
goodness
I have to go to e7 so this is how I lose
to this guy stumble into stupid opening
traps how do I get back King they're
somehow out of this mess I never go back
maybe just six
he wants to play c7 and then check me
but and I really cannot do much about
that I have to play for compensation
here
you can go c7 Quincy 796 check that's
probably not not the end of the world
no just place normal and good moves this
is just better it's just better okay if
I go back I'm still c7 hmm especially
difficult to get get something
coordinated here this one I don't know
it's just a bad position
yeah I have to go back i reassure play
d5 huh earlier
least I'm not down on time the position
sucks but at least I'm not losing on
time okay
let's kick him back I'm just taking this
this bloody pawn some kind of I mean
compensation is wrong I'm it's just
equal material but I think I definitely
had a worse position than that earlier
it's still looking bad but it was
probably even even worse
am I getting my three trapped again that
that shouldn't happen really please not
again but I can okay 94 maybe okay not
what I wanted
that's tough
so let's see can I activate this a
little bit that bishop there can still
play Knight c4 which you didn't do okay
I'm it's so bad it's really so bad check
yeah mighty Gandhi - well that looks it
sucks it really sucks but I don't seem
don't see something right
I still ask that strong Seaborn
hmm see how is he covering it now
Luke see one galaxy eight
now you might have a tactic here but I
can take the six now right no I didn't
receive one okay
takes root chicks
I'll just surround the porn yeah it can
still not take it I guess
check-check
check
I'm warning ya like him that's a good
idea but the position is just totally
lost is the thing he's got Queen b7 it's
it's just not just not possible and we
can click and play here for Queen even
one Miriam check
check so maybe I can draw with Queens
III here check check check
so I saved a draw from the gem from that
from that totally rotten position yeah
I've made this opening mistake earlier
I've made the same mistake again really
really I'm just an idiot right I have to
take first of course and then play b6
right head still goes
now that doesn't work how do I do that
96 then huh
this is right maybe ah anyway so I saved
the draw in that game at the end I had
some bad results lost again this is some
that earlier that only a game that that
French game okay
so I hope you enjoyed our show here I
think it was some bit some enjoyable
games and I have to say one thing I'm
absolutely hoping to be online next week
on Monday there is a slight chance that
I'm not online if something is getting
screwed up with my internet connection
my new place if I'm having a decent
connection I'll definitely be online but
I'm not sure if it works I hope you'll
join me if I'm on thanks for watching
guys bye bye
you